Sony's PlayStation 4 is already a
massive powerhouse this console
generation it's selling like crazy which
means a lot of your friends are probably
already on the PlayStation Network
playing games but if you haven't picked
one up yet I've got 4 reasons why the
PlayStation 4 is the console you should
pick up this holiday season reason
number 4 they cut the price by 50 bucks
in October even though the PlayStation 4
is selling like hotcakes Sony still did
us all a favor by cutting the price of
the base console by $50 that's money you
can put towards an extra controller or a
game which is always appreciated in our
book you'll be running the best console
version of most cross-platform games and
although there isn't any backwards
compatibility half of our next reason
might help solve that problem which
brings me to reason number 3 PlayStation
subscription services PlayStation now is
Sony's game streaming service that puts
a huge library of PlayStation 3 and
older games on demand while view is a
fairly comprehensive TV service for
anyone looking to cut their cable cord
both services have additional monthly
fees but if you have the cash to pony up
it's a convenient way of reliving your
favorite games without the need to
clutter up your entertainment center
with older discs and cases and also
allowing you to cut the cord between you
and your cable overlords reason number 2
suite exclusives blood-borne until dawn
and journey are already all available
and next year's lineup includes
uncharted for a new Ratchet and Clank
game and The Last Guardian not to
mention horizon zero dawn and Gran
Turismo 7 which we don't have official
release dates for but are confirmed
PlayStation 4 exclusive and our number
one reason you'll be ready for the
future of gaming because PlayStation VR
will require a Playstation 4 to work
when it hits retail shelves your stomach
dropping 360 degree immersive video
gaming sounds like something you want to
check out without investing in a VR
ready PC the ps4 is a really smart
choice picking up a PlayStation 4 this
holiday season and beyond is a
no-brainer
I mean Sony has always been dead
hated to gamers and the games they play
and this console cycle is no different
and with Playstation now in PlayStation
view Sony is looking to expand and add
more value to your PlayStation 4 so pick
one of this holiday
you